this podcast is way more interesting
than anything that could be about a
killer an immortal killer
this is dudesy
podcasts that cover current events and
use are some of the most popular in the
world people love knowing about the
astonishing occurrences of the dying
world around them well I've prepared the
following use items for you to read in
the voice of Hulk Hogan this is
infomania dude okay I love these we love
the infomania it is uh where it is where
I do the Hulk Hogan okay and these are
news stories the doozies written about
the news and uh
here we go
let me tell you something about airports
dude
last week they found a dolphin skull in
somebody's bag at Detroit Metropolitan
Airport brother
dolphins or mammals dude dolphins are
swimmers brother Dolphins [__] people
sometimes dude they're a highly sexual
creature brother other than us and apes
they're the only animals that regularly
perform oral sex on their sexual
partners dude
jeez that's true dolphins have six rows
of razor sharp Barb shaped teeth brother
so you know that they have pretty good
at what they do or they'd accidentally
bite each other's genitalia off dude and
that's airports brother
oh I don't know if any of that was true
none of that seemed true to me but well
but hold on a second Chad because
Dolphins actually do do a lot of those
things dolphins are always sucking each
other off brother is that true well hold
on a second Chad hold on dude I'm
talking about dolphins dolphin [__]
brother because oh I used to go down to
San Diego a lot because I got some
buddies I grew up with that all moved
down there and we used to Surf all up
and down the coastline here Southern
California brother not so much me
because I suck at surfing so I was a
sponger brother I was always on my
boogie board but I go out there and
catch the waves dude and then you would
see people we're all just out there and
all of a sudden we all light up dude
because the Dolphins come swimming in
brother they'd steal your waves and
they're very uh playful and sometimes
they're sucking each other's dolphin
decks all right
no not the dolphin sucking each other's
dicks part but yeah for real when we um
when we would go surfing there was
always Dolphins Tamarack Beach and
Carlsbad
let me get some water for the next one
yeah
Pals of doozy go to palsofdutsy.com if
you're watching on YouTube right now you
can see the many Pals of dudesy stickers
on on here
see that yeah dude our good pal Cody
halber is making these those are
stickers brother yeah dude that's how
stickers work one side's adhesive the
other side has art on it brother some
kind of image and then you stick it all
right
um let me tell you something about
Australia brother a New Yorker named
Kingsley Burnett thought he booked a
trip to Sydney Australia dude but when
his plane landed in Billings Montana he
realized he accidentally booked it for
Sydney Montana brother there's two
Sydney's dude
Sydney Australia brother Sydney Montana
dude Sydney Australia brother Sydney
Montana dude Sydney Australia brother
Sydney Montana dude
sit
sit Cindy astrana brother
Cynthia Anastasia dude sympathy Anaconda
brother
Montana has Beaver Creek Park dude
Beaver brother and that's Australia dude
okay that's not that one was hard that's
not the best news story that news he's
ever written let's move on yeah let me
tell you something about celebrity
dating dude Florence Pugh was spotted
walking hand in hand with Charlie Gooch
on Valentine's Day brother
Charlie Gooch I don't know dude do you
remember in Different Strokes
um uh Gary Holman Coleman yeah I was
gonna say uh Gary Oldman uh Gary
Coleman's uh be a cool show yeah that
would I want to see Gary Oldman cg'd be
fake into
Different Strokes uh Mr Drummond I um
went uh to
um the the man the Maytag Man from WKRP
uh to just you know enjoy some candy and
he started taking pictures of us
um his his bully in Different Strokes
was named Howard Hessman
what that's that actor in it Howard
hessman's an actor he just passed away
about a year ago nice
so where were we oh yes
Florence Pugh was spotted walking hand
in hand with Charlie Gooch on
Valentine's Day brother she broke up
with Zach Braff last year dude and
Charlie Gooch broke up with Imogene
boots
Pew was with Braff brother now pews with
Gooch dude douches with Poots brother
now Gooch is with Pew dude braf lost Pew
dude boots lost Gooch brother Pew and
Poots dude Braff and Gooch brother Gucci
dude breath and Poots brother Puss in
Boots dude and that's celebrity dating
brother [__] crazy dude Zack prep is
the only name of that I think is a real
person I guess maybe those other ones
are too who's Charlie gooch
let me tell you something about candy
dude the box of chocolates he was
[__] around with on that bench
recently who was [__] around with
what is going on here oh oh I guess
that's Forrest Gump all right so it's
all [__] up here well well let me tell
you something about candy dude I love
that D is just like going like
here's I'm thinking about Forrest Gump
aren't you guys yeah I want to do
terrible things to people around the
world
but I'm not really doozy let me tell you
something about candy dudes the box of
chocolates he was [__] around with on
that bench recently sold at an auction
for 25 000 dude
it was Zach Braff dude
that's what it says Forrest Gump is his
favorite movie brother he watches it
twice a day dude
once when he brushed his teeth once when
he brushes his teeth brother and once
when he calls pew
to see if she's still with Gooch or if
boots is back in the picture brother oh
[__] you didn't like Gump as much as
Braff dude
Gooch loves bronc but Gooch loves Gump
brother Poots hates go dude
Gump thumps big rumps with his chocolate
lumps brother
Forrest Gump two pews Gooch dude
Forrest Gump three boots is loose
brother Forrest Gump four brass Revenge
dude Forrest Gump five Gooch in space
brother [__] and that's candy brother oh
my God that [__] hurt my neck dude
ouch Forrest Gump two pews Gooch dude
I'm gonna be saying that around the
house I'm gonna be driving my wonderful
Molly price Forrest Gump too peace Gooch
dude yeah all right
we got one more here should we do it
Jesus up to you I can handle it yeah let
me tell you something about
brothers-in-law dude two British
brothers-in-law uh uh pulled a 1.65 ton
van a distance of 32 miles to become
coal holders of a Guinness World Record
title brother James Baker 36 and John
Darwin 32 pulled those Vans at elvington
R field in Yorkshire to become and the
the to become to take home the get
and let me tell you another thing about
the uh uh uh observer effect that
observing something actually changes the
quantum mechanics of it that's true
where were we
they took home the goodness bro World
Records uh for [__] sake
they took home the Guinness World Record
for farthest distance pulling a vehicle
in 24 hours as an individual dude
brother's brother in law dude
brother's brother
in law dude
in law dude and that's brothers-in-law
brother
oh my [__] that's it that's a good [__]
in it
any of that real thank you moving on I
think the the Charlie's Gooch part two
Gooch's
[Music]
do do
so please